[Music]
so listen to this I have this awesome
new app idea that's going to
revolutionize the tech industry
but in order to build it I first need to
figure out my tech stack
like many web applications I need a rich
front-end web interface a simple backend
API service and a high scale database
Hmm this sounds like a great use case
for the mean stack
howdy my name is Doug Parker and I'm an
engineer on the angular team at Google
I'm here today to show you how to build
and deploy a mean stack application to
Google Cloud
first of all what is the mean stack
mean is an acronym of a few web
Technologies which include mongodb a
popular document database system
Express a framework for implementing a
JavaScript web server
angular a front-end framework for
building rich and engaging web
applications
and node.js a runtime for executing
JavaScript outside the browser
with the mean stack we have everything
we need to build a compelling web
experience and I'm going to use this
superpower to build a new application
which will take the online messaging
Space by storm
I call it
meaningful tweets my new social media
platform where users can post their most
uplifting and supportive content
helping each other just get through the
day when we really need it the most
users see a list of all tweets on the
site and can post their own meaningful
tweets to support others
so how are we going to build this
using the mean stack we can develop this
fully functioning High scale web
application with three tiers
the first here is our front-end web
application built with angular users
directly interact with this front-end to
view and post tweets
the second tier is our backend web
server built with Express
the application requests tweak content
from this server which mediates access
to the underlying database
the third tier is our [ __ ] database
this stores all the Tweets in our
application
node.js lies underneath the whole stack
it supports the Project's build tooling
as well as runtime execution of both the
front end and back-end servers
beyond the mean stack we have a few
additional Technologies and patterns to
help with the process
Cloud build compiles and containerizes
our application with minimal setup
Cloud run deploys and executes these
containers on a fully managed serverless
platform meaning I don't have to worry
about provisioning nodes
mongodb Atlas similarly provides a fully
managed [ __ ] database easily accessible
from Google Cloud
we'll also be developing the whole
project using a mono repository meaning
we'll have exactly one repository
storing all our source code
this eases integration between the
different projects and allows us to
share common infrastructure
now to build the application
for the sake of time I won't go step by
step through the whole process but
instead cover just the most important
highlights of how to structure and
deploy meaningful tweets
does a GitHub repository set up with the
final State and instructions on how to
set it up in your Cloud project
you can also look through the commit
history to see all the details of each
particular step
first we'll generate the front end with
the angular CLI
we install it globally with npm I'm
using version 14 of the angular CLI the
current latest
then use NG new with the create
application false flag to create a new
mono repository which will host
meaningful tweets
within that mono repository we use NG
generate to create a new angular
application
lastly we add angular Universal which
automatically configures server-side
rendering and gives improved performance
so I have a small front-end interface
where users can create meaningful tweets
and see a list of all posted tweets
currently everything is stored in memory
on the client so a refresh loses all the
data but we'll fix it later
now that I've so effortlessly built my
front end let's deploy it to Google
Cloud
before we get too far we'll need to make
a couple minor changes to the
application
first we'll update npm start to run
build SSR followed by serve SSR
Cloud run will look at the package.json
and execute npm start
this change makes your Cloud run
executes the production build with
server-side rendering
second we'll move our Dev dependencies
into regular dependencies and reinstall
to update the lock file
Cloud run doesn't install Dev
dependencies and will need them to build
our angular app
with that out of the way we can start by
visiting Cloud console to make an
application and create a new project
called you guessed it meaningful tweets
next we'll need the gcloud CLI tool to
configure deployments for our
application
once installed start by setting the
gcloud project to meaningful tweets so
all our future commands apply to that
project
next deploy the application via the
gcloud Run deploy command
this will set up a new service called
front end and deploy it based on the
current Source directory
you'll be prompted to enable some apis
like Cloud build and Cloud run these are
what make it possible to deploy without
having to worry about containers or
nodes
the configuration is fully inferred from
my package.json file generated by the
angular CLI
if deployment fails don't worry you
might just need to raise the memory
limits to build your application
after the first attempted deployment
you'll use you'll see a new service in
Cloud console containing everything you
need to configure your service
go to edit and deploy a new revision and
raise the memory capacity to two
gigabytes
you might also want to set the minimum
instances to one just so you don't have
to deal with cold starts while you're
hacking in the cloud
once the deployment succeeds you can
click the URL at the top of the service
page to check out your app running in
the cloud
we've now got the front end running and
it's even server side rendered with
almost no additional effort
but all the data is currently stored
client-side it's lost as soon as I
refresh the page or open a new tab
I can't share meaningful tweets if no
one can see them
what we need is a shared backend server
to manage the state between different
users
so check out this new backend built with
Express and typescript
I've added two endpoints tweets new and
tweets lists
the former lets you post a new tweet
while the latter lets you see altwoots
so how can we deploy this backend to
Google Cloud
we're currently deploying just a
front-end service to Cloud run
but now we'll need to deploy two
services our existing front end and a
new backend
since there's only one source repository
but two Services we need to tell Cloud
run which one we want to deploy for
which service
we can do this by restructuring our
package.json a little bit
to start I updated my npm scripts to
consolidate all my front end related
functionality into npm run front-end
colon commands
these include the development server
build test and deploy commands
next I made a similar scripts for my
back end to make local execution and
testing easier
my favorite commands in here are the
deploy scripts which use gcloud run
deploy
this way I don't have to remember the
exact arguments each time I push to
production
on first run the backend deploy script
will set up a new backend service in the
cloud console interface
finally it's time for the magic trick
that lets us deploy two services from
the same Source Repository the trick is
simple
just update the start script to be npm
run this allows us to use npm start to
run any script in this repository based
on its given argument
for instance npm start front-end Dev
will execute the develop the front end's
development build just like npm run
front-end Dev would do
then in each Cloud console service
definition we can add a container
argument
this argument gets passed in to npm
start which means we can use it to pick
which script to run
I set the front end service to run the
production front end build while the
backend service runs the production back
end build
now I'm able to deploy two services from
the same repository so I've got my
backend hosted in the cloud
the next step is to get the front end
and back-end Services talking to each
other
currently the front end keeps all its
data in memory when it really should be
fetching from the back end
One non-obvious Challenge is that the
front end needs to know what URL the
back end is hosted at which actually
varies based on context
when running in production it should
fetch from the production backend URL in
the cloud but when running locally on my
laptop it should fetch from localhost to
access the back end's development build
to do this we can use angular
environments angular supports multiple
build environments for your application
and lets you customize environment
specific data for each
find the environment.ts file under the
front end project add a new property
called backend origin and set it to the
localhost URL of the backend
this value is used for development
builds
next make a similar change to the
environment.prod.ts file adding the same
property now set to the production
backend URL this value is used for
production builds
fortunately Google cloud service URLs
are stable so we don't need to worry
about setting up a domain name for our
backend
now when we import from environment
we'll get the localhost URL in a Dev
build and that backend service URL in a
production build multiple users can see
the same meaningful tweets and traffic
is starting to increase
since these servers are deployed with
Cloud run they can Auto scale up to meet
traffic demands so my infrastructure
scales with my needs
only one problem
state is still stored in memory just on
the front and on the back-end server
five users on a single back-end server
works just fine but as traffic increases
and we get multiple backend servers they
aren't sharing the same tweets meaning
different users see different tweets
what we need is a database to store a
global list of all tweets shared by all
backend servers enter mongodb
[ __ ] serves as the data storage layer
of the mean stack and will host all our
tools so how can we connect our backend
to a [ __ ] database
we can update the backend service to use
the mongodb npm package which provides a
comprehensive client library for working
with a [ __ ] database
when a user saves a tweet the back end
will connect to the [ __ ] cluster and
insert a tweet into the collection
when the user reads all tweets the back
end will similarly find all the Tweets
in that collection
as for where the database is storing
this information actually is for now
I've just hard-coded a localhost URL for
the back end to connect to
we can test this by installing mongodb
from the website and running it locally
by executing mongod
by running the database in one terminal
and the back end in another they're able
to easily connect with each other
posting a tweet to the back end saves it
into the database instead of storing it
in memory
I can prove this by restarting the
backend server without losing any data
listing tweets still shows the tweet I
posted before the restart so the data
must be stored in the database
so I've got my [ __ ] database working
locally but how can I deploy it to the
cloud
to set up this database I'll use mongodb
Atlas a fully managed hosting solution
for mongodb
visit the mongodb website to create an
account and make a new project called
meaningful tweets
then make a [ __ ] database cluster to
host our tweets we can pick between a
few different pricing options and
there's even a free tier for low traffic
workloads which is a great way to try it
out
I'll start there even though I know
meaningful tweets is such a good idea
I'll definitely outgrow the free tier
let's host it in Google cloud of course
and I'm in the United States so we'll
put the cluster there
lastly I'll name this cluster tweets
since that's what it's going to be
storing
[ __ ] then prompts to add a user for
service to authenticate with
I'll call this user back end since
that's the service which will connect
with this user
generate a password and copy it for
later we'll need that in just a bit
now we have a brand new fully managed
[ __ ] database hosted in the cloud
just like how the front end needed to
pick between the development and
production backends we'll also need to
pick between development and production
databases
to make this configurable in the backend
service we'll remove the hard-coded
localhost string
instead we'll set up the server to read
the database connection string from an
environment variable called mongodb URI
we'll set this variable in production in
just a moment but if it's not set we can
assume the back end is being run locally
and connect to the localhost database
we could also hard code the production
database connection string and its
password in the server source code
however this repository is open source
and doing so would leak this credential
and Associated user data to anyone
looking at the code base
only my code is allowed to accidentally
delete the database and I can't allow
just anybody to do that
to use the password securely in
production we'll set up secret manager a
service in Google Cloud for maintaining
Secrets which integrates with Cloud run
in Cloud console go to security secret
manager and enable the API
then create a new secret called mongodb
prod URI which will hold the production
database connection string
to get this string open mongodb Atlas
and click connect
It'll ask what IP addresses we want to
connect from for Simplicity let's allow
access from anywhere though in a real
app you might want to restrict to just
the back ends API address for improved
security
finally click connect your application
and copy the string
paste this string into secret manager
and include the password from earlier
you can copy over that now did you
secret manager will store the string
securely while also making it available
to our services in Cloud run
then expose the secret as an environment
variable and name that variable mongodb
URI
since the back end is already set up to
read this environment variable I can
just redeploy it and verify that
everything is working
so let's give our production application
a quick test
I can save and view Tweets in my app and
they're now persisted across refreshes
and different users
we can also confirm that tweets are
stored in the database by browsing
collections on the mongodb website
this means our servers are fully
stateless and we can Auto scale them as
much as we need to meet that traffic
Spike from earlier congratulations we've
now successfully developed a mean stack
application and deployed it to Google
Cloud
we have a local build for testing and
iterative development with easy
deployments to an integrated and fully
managed production environment
one billion users here we come
that's all I have time for today but if
you want to keep going with this project
there are a number of cool improvements
you can look into
more comprehensive build tooling like
bazel NX or Turbo repo would make it
easier to build and develop locally as
well as share code between multiple
projects in large repositories
continuous integration setup can make
sure tests pass and auto deploy a new
version of the service so you don't have
to think about deployment so much
it can also be helpful to set up a
staging environment for pre-production
testing
and you can always just add more
services a new front-end hosting an
internal dashboard of user metrics a new
backend to handle user profiles more
complex database schema to host all that
data the project structure can grow and
scale as you need it
you can also integrate with countless
Google Cloud apis want to provide some
automation to make sure meaningful
tweets are actually meaningful
connect the cloud natural language API
and get full sentiment analysis in
minutes
need to make sure your service stays
reliable configure Cloud monitoring to
track your service across defined slos
and alert when things go wrong
there's so many awesome features to
explore the only limit is your
creativity
check out the GitHub repository for Full
Source Code and instructions on how to
deploy it to your own Google Cloud
instance
Fork the repository deploy it and
convert it into your own billion user
idea now if you'll excuse me it's time
for the most important part of the
project getting a domain name
wait you mean I can do my domain name on
Google Cloud 2
[Music]